If you look out over the water, you can see one of Rochester's most recognizable buildings
in the distance, Kodak headquarters. This is the company most often associated with Rochester,
and it's because of Kodak that Rochester has been coined the imaging capital of the world.
George Eastman, Kodak's founder, introduced the Kodak camera in 1888, revolutionizing the way
people took photos. People could now take a picture by simply pressing a button, a simplistic idea
Kodak used in their early marketing with the slogan, you push the button, we do the rest.
Kodak's rise to prominence was largely driven by their effective use of advertising and their
groundbreaking ability to simplify photography. They transformed a task once reserved for professionals
into something accessible to the average person. Kodak failed to fully embrace the potential of
digital cameras, which led to them losing hold of their dominant market share, just like Xerox
and Baush and Lomb. The big three couldn't keep up with the technological advancements that were
happening in the world as they were slow to realize the new potential of digital technology in
photographic sciences and failed to invest in its innovation. As time went on, the same consumers who
hailed these companies for their genius inventions moved to new technology from other companies.
The companies began major layoffs and soon there were tens of thousands of unemployed workers
within the Rochester community.